all right a bunch of you sent this to me
and i want to actually take the time to
go through it
there's a clip making the rounds on the
internet
called charlie kirk destroys crazy
eco-nut student that's the title of the
clip charlie kirk is
sort of like a ben shapiro type
character who goes to college campuses
and he debates
college students and he speaks very
confidently and people in the background
clap and it sort of comes off like
charlie kirk is
smart and um articulate and
factual most importantly it comes off
like he's owning these college kids with
facts and logic
and he's not and that's why this format
that these right-wingers have developed
is so terrible so let's calmly go
through it this is about climate change
a a student who is admittedly not well
prepared tries to confront charlie kirk
about um uh anthropogenic climate change
meaning human-caused climate change and
charlie kirk comes off like he's doing a
good job
but it's all bs okay so let's just let's
take it one claim at a time and tell me
if this is useful no question we'll be
here
what's the last question
sorry we got it sorry thank you uh yeah
first of all sorry for laughing when you
were talking about that appointment uh
because it's just completely ridiculous
for you to suggest that
can you prove to me carbon dioxide is
the only reason why the atmosphere is
heating
okay
so already we have a problem
can you prove to me
that carbon dioxide is the only reason
why the atmosphere is heating so we can
now calmly think about that number one i
don't know anybody claiming that heating
is the only way we notice climate change
we're talking about erratic and extreme
weather more record highs more record
lows unseasonable weather extreme
weather events like storms sea level
rise uh etc okay so so
charlie kirk is asking for a defense to
a claim that's not even a good claim and
then number two
co2 is the cause of climate change i
mean we're really talking co2 is one of
the ways that we see the impact that
we're having but we're really talking
about activities generating electricity
by burning fossil fuels manufacturing
and industry emissions which release
numerous gases co2 being one
deforestation using transportation
producing food powering buildings they
all relate to emissions and emissions
include co2
but it's overly simplistic to say co2 is
the cause itself
well trees need co2 so we shouldn't be
worried about that that's the claim they
like to make
the point is everything is falling out
of balance and when he frames the
question in this simplistic way
prove
prove that carbon dioxide is the only
reason climate is warming we're not
talking only about carbon dioxide and
we're not talking only about warming
okay next they move on to sun spots the
only reason necessarily also it's not
just carbon dioxide because there's
methane and there's a lot of other uh
gases greenhouse gases are causing uh
climate change like this is a huge
driver in climate change and do you
think sunspots have any sort of
contributing factor
not to a point where we can say that
that it's not so why is it that okay
sunspots charlie kirk says well maybe
sunspots are the reason for climate
change well climate scientists agree
that sunspots and even solar wind could
play a role in warming but warming is
only one aspect of climate change and
the role of sunspots has been studied
the vast majority of climate scientists
say the role of sunspots is
minimal absolutely minimal
and really the causes of of climate
change are industrial activity there are
thousands of peer-reviewed studies to
back that up now you can come in and say
well all of the science is just wrong
all of those scientists are wrong and
later in the segment charlie kirk does
basically say that but now you're
arguing that they're getting everything
wrong and could science get something
wrong of course but is it likely that at
this point they're getting everything
wrong on this issue no it's not
particularly likely so now let's
continue and now they they use it
charlie crook uses another talking point
say that that's just not it so why is it
that in northern scotland back in the
1700s they had a mediterranean climate
what made that change the climate
fluctuates naturally oh it does okay
so this is another popular talking point
if industrialization is responsible for
climate change why was it so much warmer
in northern scotland in the 1700s than
it is today why this has been widely
studied and there's actually four of
these examples that are often cited uh
northern scotland was mediterranean
uh there were vineyards in england
england in general was warmer and there
were
vineyards during the medieval period
because it was so much warmer greenland
used to actually be green
uh newfoundland was full of grapes
meaning it also had a much milder
climate
so it's been studied these this is not
new ground the idea with charlie kirk is
he says this stuff to people who have
never heard it before
some of these beliefs are based on tree
ring data
tree ring data is not the most accurate
for evaluating temperature since it can
be affected by rainfall and some other
things but it's something and it's quite
possible that there were some warmer
moments before industrialization that's
not really a big deal
second it's not clear that in all of
these popular examples newfoundland
greenland etc it's not clear that
they're actually referring to the
specific places on earth that we think
they are because there have been changes
to the way we as humans refer to
different places so part of it is they
may be actually referring to slightly
different locations longitudinally and
latitudinally number three
no one's denying that there have been
periods
of warmer and colder climate over time
on earth the issue is that there has
been a consistency globally
to the warming over the last 100 years
and particularly the last 30 years than
at any time during the medieval period
so you could identify some microclimate
differences
you know microclimate being like san
francisco if you go just north or south
of san francisco it's like super hot a
lot of the year but in san francisco
it's cooler
you can identify microclimates whether
they're scotland or whatever it doesn't
disprove anything about the broader
climate change caused by
industrialization um okay let's let's
continue next they get to uh temperature
fluctuations yes yes this is outside of
human emissions no no no okay look
listen to me right now you're clapping
it shows ignorance right there because
yes there's natural fluctuations in
temperature however
humans are causing climate change we we
know this the evidence shows it and
you're being ignorant honestly okay so
what evidence are you talking about okay
so this is where they kind of love to
wrap you up or you go well it's only
huma human activity causing climate
change and then they get you to admit
well no there are some natural
fluctuations again you can't fall into
this stuff of course there are
fluctuations over time we've had ice
ages and then the ice ages end nobody's
denying that
what we know right now
is that much of the change that we're
seeing is not at all natural it's
happening much more rapidly than other
natural fluctuations have happened
and when you look at ice cores which let
us see conditions going back 800
thousand years when you look at pollen
remains and ocean sediment and glaciers
and more you know today that there is
much more methane in the atmosphere than
at any time in the last eight hundred
thousand years these are not little
fluctuations that go with ice age or
whatever uh and we can see over a longer
period of time now uh then they get into
whose evidence can you believe whose
views can you believe ipcc climate
change report so 97 of scientists agree
that one yes the science of democracy
we vote on do we vote on gravity
we reach consensus
the way the scientists are trying to
consensus
with a consensus on newton's second law
here's the problem i want to know what
yeah there's consensus no it's a hundred
percent because it's proof you can't
prove it here's the issue yeah yeah we
don't have an up or down vote on things
like you're not a scientist i want to
know what the three percent belief you
know why because usually the three
percent dissenting opinion against the
majority is the one that we should
listen to the most that's called the
scientific method so that's just wrong i
mean it's unless you have some
particular reason to believe that the
three percent is correct and the 97
percent is wrong there's no particular
reason that we should listen more to the
three percent than the 97 percent and
even that number is wrong it's really
more like 99.8 and 0.2 percent uh but
that's just that's just a
that that's a meaningless claim listen
to the minority more why well i mean
okay listen to what they're saying but
why why do we give them more weight i'm
pro-science you're pro-mobocracy you're
pro-hysteria you're pro panic
and by the way you're completely
ignoring the positive effects of a
changing climate for example the world
has never been greener did you know that
did you ever know that we have more
grassland and more farmland able to be
used for consumption than ever before do
you know that okay so that's not really
true what that this talking point the
earth has never been greener
it's it's really only relative to like a
few decades ago and it is it is in a
sense true that over the last two
decades
earth has increased its green leaf area
by a total of about five percent now one
of the major reasons for that is that
we're starting with a lower baseline the
deforestation of the 1970s
in particular
left us at a very low starting point and
over the last 20 years china and india
have done massive tree planting
campaigns so they've sort of
artificially bumped up the amount of
green leaf areas there are questions
about whether this artificial greening
has the same carbon capture power that
one might imagine and the answer appears
to be no but this this is comparing to
the massive deforestation of the 70s and
80s let's get now to his claims about um
the safety of cold versus hot used for
consumption never before do you know
that less people live in extreme cold
than ever before and this whole climate
fluctuation okay
he i think he means fewer people but he
says less people live in extreme cold
than ever before they claim that this
like it's a good thing
heat kills way more people than cold
okay way more people on earth have the
ability to heat themselves when it's
cold than to cool themselves when it's
hot if you look at the availability of
fire
versus air conditioning heat related
deaths over time are estimated to be
more than five million people a year
uh because uh actually no five five
million is because of extreme heat or
cold the majority of that is because of
heat
and uh heat-related deaths are are on
the rise whereas cold related deaths are
not in the united states it's also known
that heat kills more people than cold
and this is even accounting for you know
the
this idea of the the homeless person out
in the cold in the winter
heat kills way more people so the idea
that it's good for humanity it doesn't
make any sense whatsoever let's listen
to the last bit nonsense we're only
dealing with a hundred year data set we
know that the world that the climate
naturally fluctuated okay so that's the
last thing i'll talk about the hundred
year data set
what they mean when they say that is
that modern historical weather and
temperature records only go back to
about the 1880s it's like 140 150 years
so it's true that modern weather data
only goes back that far when people
started measuring temperature more or
less the way we do now but as i
mentioned before we have 800 000 years
of ice melt cycles we have glacier data
that's much older we have ocean
sedimentary data pollen layers and more
things so
the kid confronting charlie kirk is
unprepared no question whatsoever but
the arguments that charlie kirk makes
are all bad and in that format there's
no opportunity to really explore it but
when you break it down piece by piece
you see that that is exactly what it is
it's simply nonsense let me know if
these types of clips are useful i do
what i can
when it comes to climate change because
this is one of the most important issues
of our time if we don't have a planet
it's hard to do much about women's
rights or campaign finance or whatever
and i do whatever i can at the
individual level bearing in mind that
corporations also have to change a lot
to reduce my climate footprint this
includes being aware of how far is my
food coming from or how much trash am i
generating these types of things and
this is why our sponsor rent is so
important ren is a chartered public
benefit company and they unlock the
collective action of individuals against
climate change and ren is a very simple
and effective way to make a difference
on climate rent is a website where you
calculate your carbon footprint
personally you answer a few questions
about your lifestyle
wren will then tell you what your carbon
footprint is and let you offset it
by funding a diverse mix of carbon
reduction projects like tree planting uh
mineral weathering rainforest protection
once you sign up to make a monthly
contribution to offset your carbon
footprint you'll get monthly updates
from the projects you support and you'll
get to see
where is your money going you'll see
photos you'll get details it will take a
lot to end the climate crisis but you
can start offsetting your carbon
footprint today and ren will cover the
first month of your subscription for
free
when you sign up at ren dot co slash
david the link is down below